okay the hatred mail calendars for 2016
are available and they are starting to
go out you can get yours at david
pakman.com slash calendar 16 i still
don't have mine yet i'll remind you this
is the that i'm holding up for our TV
audience this is the 2015 hatred mail
calendar and every page has a different
custom image created by a david pakman
show viewer related to hatred mail this
is a really good conversation piece
people tell me that they have the 2015
calendar in their office or in their
other cubicle wall and that it creates
many interesting conversations a lot of
funny stories from coworkers and that
type of thing in 2015 we shipped a
hundred twenty two of these calendars my
goal for the 2016 calendar is to ship
out 200 of them after day one we had
nine calendars ordered so we are well on
our way given that we we just started
selling these you can get a calendar
autographed or not autographed and
option number two is you can get the
calendar for free with a yearly
membership but there's there's only one
website where you can do all of this and
that's it david pakman.com slash
calendar 16 get just the calendar or get
the calendar for free with a yearly
membership and then you'll get the bonus
show in the commercial free audio feed
in the commercial free video feed and
you'll be invited to next month's town
hall meeting with Luis and with me where
you can ask us questions in a private
video conference just with our
membership base and you get the calendar
for free so you really can't go wrong
with that david pakman.com slash
calendar 16 today may well be the last
david pakman show before we move the
studio to boston massachusetts every
indication as far as i am aware of right
now which which is very i know i'm
creating all sorts of disclaimers to the
best of my knowledge as of this exact
second we will be moving to the new
studio over the weekend and as a result
we will probably have a couple of days
off at the beginning of next week to get
that new studio set up once Louis
returns from his trip and we get the
whole thing going I
talk about it more on the bonus show
today which if you were a member you'd
be able to get all the details about so
I recommend signing up and get yourself
a free calendar david pakman.com slash
calendar 16 we have great audience
questions to answer today and so much
other great stuff happening on this
friday show